[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
seven 800-835-6740 seven
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor hi
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
the city of dubai in the united arab
emirates is home to the biggest man-made
island tallest skyscraper tallest hotel
tallest fountain and now holds the
record for the world's deepest swimming
pool
today it's hard to find a swimming pool
that's over eight feet deep i'm always
disappointed because i like going to the
deep end and
trying to uh hold my breath
but
in deep dive dubai this new facility
it plunges over
196 feet deep it's a depth that's
already set the guinness world record as
the deepest swimming pool in the world
below its surface lies an entire
underworld designed to resemble a sunken
city
explorers can suit up in diving gear and
play underwater billiards foosball or
chess or they can just explore the
depths of the expansive multi-themed
facility according to its owners it
takes several dives to see everything
3.6 million gallons of crystal clear
water as much as six olympic-sized
swimming pools contain an abandoned city
an apartment an arcade and much more
non-divers can watch friends and loved
ones from the facility's built-in
restaurant
prices begin at four hundred dollars to
scuba dive and a hundred dollars for a
friend to just watch
the facility's indoors and its fresh
water is kept at 85 degrees fahrenheit
for comfortable diving
if a diving emergency does occur there's
a hyperbaric chamber that can fit 12
people
it's interesting to consider the world's
deepest pool is built in one of the
world's biggest deserts you know pastor
ross the bible tells us that god is
going to do the same thing in the future
i know pastor dave that's a fascinating
fact it seems like all of these mega
cities are trying to
outpace the next city and of course
dupay has a lot of money and they're
always building something new you
mentioned the highest building and of
course they have i believe it's dubai
it's one of those those cities there
that have an indoor
um
place where you can snow ski i've been
there it is in dubai it's in their mall
which is huge and now they have the
deepest swimming pool it's not really a
swimming pool that people go to laps and
it's really for diving you've got to
have a
the right gear and you actually go down
and
i bet that's something you'd like to do
you know i would i don't know if i'd go
down the hole i think the deepest i've
been
diving is probably 120 feet 196 feet
there's a lot of ear popping that goes
down there that is very deep and they
had to reinforce because the air the
water pressure at that depth is so
powerful they had to do some very
creative engineering to make sure that
it didn't just blow out the concrete
at the base of it but you think about
i'm going to go to the desert and go
dive into the deepest pool
and i think the second biggest desert is
saudi arabia the first would be the
sahara
and so it is kind of interesting when
you think about it but it made me think
of those verses in the bible where god
says
when the world is made new he's going to
take some of the places that are
considered a desert in a wilderness now
and they will blossom like the rose and
they'll be springs here's a few verses
psalm 107 35
he turns a wilderness into pools of
water and dry land into water springs
psalm 114 verse 8 who turned the rock
into a pool of water the flint into
fountains of waters of course he did
that the children of israel he gave them
water in the desert when they were going
through their wanderings there and one
more isaiah 41 verse 18
i will open rivers in desolate heights
and fountains in the midst of the valley
i will make the wilderness water and the
dry land springs of water it's going to
be fascinating to see what the world
looks like when god remakes it
and i think that even
archaeologists geologists some
paleontologists are amazed
that they go to these arctic regions
today their arctic regions or their
deserts and they find fossils
of all these ferns and tropical plants
and they said boy the world must have
really been different back then or
tilted on its axis or something because
all over the globe it seemed like it was
a paradise
and that's what god's going to do i
think he's given us an upgrade in the
new earth you know some of the people
look at the verses just quoted about
springs of water in the desert and they
think well you know is heaven really for
real can we really believe what the
bible says about this beautiful place
that god is preparing for those that
love him not only heaven up in heaven
but also the earth made new revelation
speaks about a new heavens and a new
earth here on this earth and so we do
have a book that talks about that it's
called heaven is it for real and that is
our free offer we happen to send that to
anyone who would call and ask
yes heaven israel and the bible has
quite a bit to say about heaven we'll be
happy to send anyone the book to receive
the book call 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
heaven is it for real
and if you're outside of north america
and you know pastor we've got people
listening from
different countries i know we have
people regularly listening from africa
and india and if you'd like to read the
book you can just go to the website the
amazing facts website click on the free
library and you can read the book it's
called heaven is it for real
well before we get to the phone lines
where it's like to start with the word
of prayer so let's do that now dear
father we recognize that
when we come to the bible we recognize
it's your book the holy spirit inspired
the prophets of old and lord we need the
guidance of the holy spirit if we're to
correctly understand it so be with us as
we study together be with those who are
listening wherever they might be in
their car or at home or
wherever they are lord lead us all into
a clearer and a full understanding of
bible truth before we ask this in jesus
name amen amen
all right well we're ready to go to our
first caller for today uh let's see
we've got
ryan let's go to ryan in
maine ryan welcome to the program
hey thanks for uh taking my call
absolutely
um you guys are a huge blessing in my
life i just want you to know that
oh i wish we were on more than once a
week thank you ryan
um anyway so my question is centered
around the millennium
um
so how are the saved going to really
enjoy
being one up in heaven for a thousand
years
knowing that some
loved ones and family members are not
going to be there to enjoy it with them
and that every day that passes
that's one day closer to ultimately when
they're destroyed so
yeah that's a great question
you know i think that some people think
that when we do go to heaven we suddenly
are brainwashed and we're just sort of
like injected with this happy drug
and we have no feelings anymore
revelation talks about god drying every
tear from our eyes but that's actually
happening in revelation 22.
when we first get to heaven and the
millennium is revelation 21
i think there may be some some sorrow
and some questions about loved ones that
are not there and that's why it says the
books are open i think we're we're able
to look at the books paul says you'll
judge angels
and so we'll be engaged in seeing that
god did everything he could to save our
loved ones
and that he really had no alternative so
it's during that time in the millennium
you know we may have angels are not
always happy i think angels cry
when jesus was on the cross
so in heaven our emotions aren't erased
and i think there may be some time when
we're going to have some introspection
and be saying i wish i'd done more
or we'll see loved ones and and you know
we'll have feelings and sorrow for that
god certainly is grieved to see anyone
lost
but when we enter the millennium at that
point god wipes away all tears all
questions are answered probably long
before it's over
but you know you're referring to that
verse um let me read the revelation 21 4
this is at the creation of the new earth
that says and god will wipe away every
tear from their eyes there will be no
more death no sorrow no crying there
shall be no more pain for the former
things have passed away but that is as
you mentioned at the end of that 1000
year period right exactly so hope that
helps ryan we do actually have a book on
the millennium or a study guide then
we'll be happy to send you a free copy
it's called a thousand years of peace
maybe you've seen this before ryan if
not call and ask for it the whole study
just on that revelation 20 000 years of
peace
800-835-6747 that is the resource phone
line if you call that number just ask
for the study guide on the millennium
and we'll be happy to send it to you now
if you want to call in with a question
just call 800 god says
or
800-463-7297 i see we have some lines
open
and we're also streaming this on
facebook that's the amazing facts
facebook page it's live now uh we're on
af tv i believe we're on af tv we are
yeah and we're also on uh youtube live
and so there's a number of ways you can
not only listen
but
i don't know how visually edifying it is
but we're happy to have you join us okay
we've got angela listening from illinois
angela welcome to the program
hi pastor ross and uh pastor doug hi um
i have a question um can you just help
me understand uh matthew
um
11 verses 19.
i i don't understand
i was talking with someone that was
telling me that
um when i was explaining that no we're
not to you know i don't you know i don't
drink wine or
and and you know wine is not good um
and
they're telling me oh well jesus drank
wine so i
if you could just explain that i would
appreciate it sure matthew 11 you said
verse 19
yes 18 and 19. okay for john came and
speaking of john the baptist here for
john came neither eating or drinking and
they say he has a demon the son of man
came eating and drinking and they said
look a glutton and a wine bibber now
he's talking about his enemies
making accusations
not only did his enemies say that he was
a drunkard a drunkard or glutton rather
of course jesus was not a glutton a
glutton that's a person who just you
know eats
in an irresponsible way way too much and
neither was he a wine bibber or a drunk
and they also said that jesus was a
samaritan which was an insult and they
said he was demon
demon-possessed that he cast out devils
by the prince of devil so this is
recording one of the accusations it is
true
that john the baptist did a lot of
fasting a matter of fact one time the
disciples of john the baptist he must
have had some of his own apostles or
disciples they came to the disciples of
jesus and they said why is it that your
master doesn't fast
and john the baptist fasts often and
jesus said well the time's going to come
when they will fast but i'm with them
right now this is not the time so jesus
he did go to the home of publicans and
sinners and he would eat with him it was
out such a meal that mary washed his
feet and dried him with their hair
doesn't say anything about any of these
meals him getting drunk or overeating
it's just this was recording an
accusation that was made by his enemies
that he's a glutton and a wine bibber
they were going to the opposite extreme
because he ate with republicans who were
sometimes gluttons and wine beavers he
at the house of people like matthew and
zacchaeus
they assumed that he was too but i don't
think jesus ever did either and of
course he was also accused by his
enemies
as being demon possessed being
controlled by bells above so uh of
course jesus was not demon possessed so
yes they made all kinds of accusations
to try and discredit the teachings of
christ and the miracles that he was
performing
does that help angela
oh my goodness yes i was writing at the
same time so i can
well if you missed any of it you can
just go to the facebook and you can play
it back there you go
all right
all right well thanks for your call
we're glad you called uh we got jim
listening from uh let's see
i n that's indiana right
jim welcome to the program yep
yeah
thank you very much um
first off i'd like to apologize for
interrupting your meeting the other day
um
i was so taken back by the whole tour
that i got over the place oh wonderful
that's you're that gem well we're
delighted to have you come and see the
place
but uh well anyhow and i'm gonna have to
stop back by and
take another picture because i only got
half of john ross on there
well hopefully he got his better hat
yeah hopefully
and your question
was revelations uh chapter 12 verse 7
where it talks about the times times and
half of time
okay that there's a 1260-year
prophecy right yes that started in 538
yes and then
and then in um verse 11
it talks about a 1290 days
are you in revelation are you in daniel
now daniel 12 11 i think daniel okay
yeah yeah yeah it does yes
now
you know i read in revelations where it
talks about the plagues being in
says one hour in one hour and one hour
now
that 45 day period
in
daniel the same as uh
three hours in revelations
well you know some people have wondered
about that
um
when you read a day for a year in
prophecy
uh when you read you know prophecy and
talks about there were this many
days
many bible expositors know that it's
really talking about a year
i'll give you an example of that jesus
said
when herod wanted to execute christ or
you just killed john the baptist someone
told jesus he said go tell that fox
that i teach and do cures and cast out
devils today
tomorrow and the third day i'll be
completed
well jesus was only about six months
into his ministry when john was executed
he taught three more years so christ in
that prophecy he used the principle of a
day for a year
and when you look at many of the
prophecies in daniel in revelation when
it says this many 1260 days it means 1
260 years
so jim is wondering well what about when
it says one hour then
well you could do it that way like
there's says there's silence in heaven
for the spaceship revelation chapter 8
it works out too roughly using a
biblical day for a year
to about um
a half an hour would be about seven and
seven point five days yeah because it
says about the space of half an hour
probably talking about seven days yep
so then jim is saying well what about
when in revelation 18 it says for it
divides the fall of babylon in three
hours it's like it's false politically
and socially and economically it says in
one hour one hour one hour you add that
together you get 45 days
some have wondered well is that the
period of time
that the seven plagues fall and we don't
know that's the theory i've heard it's
uh
i don't know that we have anything
concrete to prove yeah what's
interesting when you're talking about
that you're talking about future events
so it's
sometimes exactly the way it is uh but
with reference to 1290 that we finally
downshift 12 that is using a day for a
year principle so we're talking about
1290 years right 1260 years also 1290
years the 1335 1 35 years so we knew
about long periods of time
we know the 1260 represents 538 till
1798.
that's when the paypal power was
established in europe the 1290 at the
beginning of that 508 a very significant
event occurred which opened the way for
the establishment of the papal power and
that was the conversion of clovis king
of the franks now we don't hear much
about it but we do know that one of the
biggest supporters of the papal power
was france
and the conversion of clovis the king
from paganism to actually
catholicism and he accepted catholicism
is a rather significant event and he
basically had to sway over all europe oh
absolutely and that's the beginning of
the holy roman empire
so that's why i think that they
specifically mentioned there yeah the
1335 will bring you right up till
1843 and what's significant about age 43
is you have the fulfillment of the 2 300
year prophecy in daniel 8 14. announcing
the end of or the beginning of that
judgment hour period the judgment time
to read about in revelation 14. so it's
a deep study a lot of interesting pieces
there to those time prophecies but i
think daniel chapter 9 is referring to a
much longer period of time than you read
about in the book of revelation when
it's talking about an hour an hour an
hour
well hope that helps jim we we
appreciate your calling and
we'll look forward to seeing you again
when you swing through the office
okay well i appreciate it i really do
yeah all right thank you thank you take
care
all right we have susie listening from
colorado susie welcome to the program
you on the air
hi
thank you
before i ask my question i just want to
say that um my son is a truck driver
and because of listening to uh pastor
doug he and his son were baptized wow so
you've been quite a blessing in our
lives
praise lord that's what we love to hear
yeah um my question is in psalms 139 16
to 18 it says before you were formed you
were written in the book
is that the book of life or what book is
that well that's a good question we know
god does have
a book he has books in heaven this one
is talking about before you were formed
uh you were written in the book it's
kind of like where the lord says that
jeremiah that i chose you as a prophet
from your mother's womb i think god is
just talking about his foreknowledge
there
i mean we do know of three books of
record in heaven right you got the book
of life did you read about in revelation
we know there's the book of remembrance
where the good deeds that have been done
are remembered and god records that in
heaven and then you have the book of sin
where every idol word jesus said you'll
give an account of in the judgment so
this includes not only what we do but
even what we say and even the thoughts
of the heart so three books of of record
in heaven of course as believers we want
our names written in the lamb's book of
life that's where it needs to be that's
where it needs to stay but when it
refers to a book here in psalms hundred
and thirty nine past that i think it's
just referring to god's knowledge god
knew i mean god knows all things and he
knows when people are formed and here
with reference to david david was
especially chosen by god god knew david
would come and it would be through the
lineage of david that of course the
messiah would come and that is something
that
has that's a good significance that's a
good point yeah
david in particular
got it said uh as soon as the child has
conceived that maybe their
their name is put in the book of life
unless it stays there unless they don't
want to be with christ
you know i don't think the children are
born
saved they're born innocent
but you really need to be born again and
you know that that goes for everybody of
course if a child dies before the age of
accountability they're found innocent
but um
yeah i think every human child
is born with the kind of fallen selfish
nature
of adam so we need that holy spirit new
birth but thank you susie i hope that
helps a little bit
oh yeah it does thank you so much all
right
thank you we've got kyle listening from
california kyle welcome to the program
hey how you guys doing
good appreciate your calling
i just had a quick question and the
question is do we need to eat from the
tree of life in order to sustain life in
heaven
you know uh we're assuming that god is
restoring his original plan for adam and
eve and with adam and eve he said very
specifically
we're going to expel them from the
garden of eden otherwise they'll eat
from the tree and live forever so there
was something they needed from the tree
to perpetuate life i mean one bite might
have lasted 500 years so it's not
you know
if they were doing it on a regular basis
they had nothing to worry about
adam who ate from the tree of life made
it 900 years
but it seems like
yeah we're going to eat in heaven god
said we'll plant vineyards and eat the
fruit i think it also is a reference to
just our faith we're acknowledging that
god is the one that gives us life yeah
and by us partaking of the fruit of the
tree and of course why wouldn't you want
to eat of the tree of life 12 different
kinds of fruit different kind of fruit
every month and we can't even begin to
imagine what type of fruit that's going
to be but the tree of life becomes a
symbol i think a symbol for the redeemed
saying you know this is
a symbol of god who ultimately gives us
life he ultimately sustains us yeah i
don't picture
that saved people are going to be off
visiting some remote world and realize
oh man i haven't had a bite of the tree
of life in three weeks i better get back
i'm gonna die yeah and be struggling you
know their last few steps to get to the
tree and eat a piece so that they can
live
i don't think you're gonna have that
kind of fear and of course remember uh
in the story of adam and eve passed that
there were angels that barred their
access to the tree of life so there was
something that the tree of life provided
that perpetuated life and god said lest
they eat of the tree and live forever
right so there was something we made a
special bible
and that shortened our life right
i like vegetables i was teasing thanks
kyle we appreciate your call we got uh
paul listening in washington paul
welcome to the program
hello hello how are you good thank you
for calling
yes uh first thessalonians chapter 14
verse four
chapters you're talking about chapter
four
first thessalonians
14. okay there we go
yeah and your question
uh
it says here so god will bring with him
those who sleep in jesus and oop i think
we might have lost
it was oscar was no who was it that we
were just talking to
his phone must have dropped off
uh so we're sorry we don't know what
happened but was that richard that are
called i forget if he calls back again
we'll try and uh bump it yeah sorry
about that
move them up in the train here yeah
absolutely all right we've got time for
the next one we'll go to oscar then in
new york oscar welcome to the program
yes sir thank you
verses 9
and 10
okay
and your question
yes
it says as he said
jesus says
to this salvation has come to this house
because he also is his son of abraham my
question is who is his son of abraham
well you know jesus said to the
religious leaders they thought they were
saved and pastor ross might find this he
said you're not of abraham you're your
father the devil
yet he called zacchaeus the son of
abraham and then paul said
if you have christ then you are
abraham's seed and so when zacchaeus
accepted jesus he was called the son of
abraham and so anyone jew or gentile
that accepts christ the bible says
there's neither jew or gentile now male
or female slave or free we're all one in
christ when a person accepts christ they
become the spiritual children of abraham
the first referring to i think is john
chapter 8 verse 39 they answered and
said to him we are abraham or abraham is
our father jesus said to them if you
were abraham's children you would do the
works of abraham but now you seek to
kill me
so um yeah so they weren't doing the
works of abraham they would they weren't
doing works of faith
um zacchaeus though was a jew
yes he was a literal child of abraham he
was working for the for the romans but
he was a jew and he became a spiritual
child of abraham when god forgave him
so he was like born again or born of god
yeah he was born of his spiritual girl
he was seeking jesus he said you'll find
me when you seek me it says he sought to
see jesus and when jesus he saw him and
i think jesus said i'm going to eat at
your house he realized that he'd been
forgiven or received by god
then he repents and he confesses
publicly and then jesus said after he
reprints and he confesses this is a
child of abraham
okay so let me just one answer one
question i may ask
now in verse 10 it says for the son of
man has come to seek and to save that
which was lost
what was what was lost
well i think jesus is saying that the
there was a child of abraham that was
lost here
and that
zacchaeus who had been you know public
and a great sinner
um when he came back to the lord
he had been lost and he was found
and of course that's one of the reasons
why the jews hated tax collectors
because many of them were jews but they
sort of sold themselves out to oppress
in their countrymen and working for
their arch enemy the romans and so for
jesus to actually show mercy to
zacchaeus and go eat at his house and
talk about him being an heir of the
promises made to abraham
that was really upsetting to the
religious leaders because they thought
because of the ancestry they had a free
ticket into heaven so to speak yeah it
doesn't work that way you know pastor
ross we're going to be going to a break
in just a minute now one minute is
sometimes under what we need to do a
good job answering the question so maybe
we'll take just a moment tell people
about something coming up very exciting
in about three weeks maybe just a little
more than three weeks we're going to be
uplinking
from
the word center here
in the sacramento area a brand new
evangelistic program
dealing with bible prophecy and there's
a lot of things that are happening in
the world today that
people sense
with everything from the pandemic
to the gyrating economy
uh international travel on hold
and
everything that's going on natural
disasters that something's going on and
we want to be talking about what the
bible has to say about the times in
which we live and kind of give a
panorama of prophecy through the bible
it's called panorama prophecy you can
find out more about how to watch it
it'll be on
3abn aftv hope channel just go to
panoramaofprophecy.com
and learn more we'll be right back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
amazing facts offer some of the best
christian resources for all ages
we hope our products will enrich your
life and your walk with the lord
life requires daily wisdom and now you
can expand your understanding in wisdom
for life pastor doug's new 31 day
devotional based on the 31 chapters from
the book of proverbs written by king
solomon
get yours today by calling 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
have you always wanted to be a bible
expert but never knew where to start
are you searching for answers that will
bring you joy peace and fulfillment
then you'll love the amazing facts
historicals of prophecy bible study
experience now available in 18 languages
featuring 24 easy-to-read lessons the
storicals are packed with scripture and
step-by-step guidance that will give you
absolute confidence about what the bible
actually says about the second coming
the rapture the antichrist and the mark
of the beast
you'll also get the truth about hell and
the afterlife and practical insight
about grace salvation and how to truly
live like jesus
even better it's absolutely free at
storacles.org
so don't miss out get started on your
bible study adventure today at
storacles.org
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history landmarks of prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by pastor
doug batchelor landmarks of prophecy is
a video bible study adventure designed
for today's audiences presenting the
landmark themes of the bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your epic bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
or by 800-538-7275 afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 pm
and 8 pm pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends the bible
answers live if you've tuned in along
the way this is a live international
bible study and you can call in with
your bible questions 800 god says that's
800-463-7297
you can also join us on tv
by watching the program on amazing facts
television it's also streaming on doug
batchelor's facebook page on the amazing
facts facebook page and the amazing
facts youtube channel and i am doug
batchelor my name is john ross and again
we want to welcome all of our friends
who are joining us if you're just
joining us halfway through the program
and you have a bible question
the phone line here to the studio is
patient they'll get to 800-463-7297 call
as soon as they can we've got michael
listening in maui michael welcome to the
program
hi good afternoon
hey hi good afternoon it's earlier for
you than it is for us but uh
we'll respect that
and your question tonight
um yes um
is the sabbath that we're following
right now from
mount sinai the same has been existed
before creation
or should i break down my question to
um
is the tenth commandment has been
existed prior to the creation
well the ten commandments uh were
cardified by the lord
i think it had been given orally and it
was really in everyone's heart i think
when god made adam uh god didn't need to
tell adam by the way don't steal and
don't kill and don't lie and don't cheat
on eve
i think that was written in their hearts
when they had the love of god because
all the law is summarized in love
but and the sabbath was something that
was really established i think for this
planet
because god rested
following his six days of creation he
set aside a day for these creatures
where they could fellowship with him in
a special way there's nothing in the
bible that says that the sabbath
predated i mean the laws did it's always
been wrong to lie
but there's nothing that i see in
scripture that tells us that the sabbath
predated the creation of our world
because it's connected it says remember
the sabbath four in six days
it's connected with the creation of this
world now i'm wondering pastor like
you're right the sabbath this every
seventh day definitely is a reference to
creation on earth and it's a memorial of
god's creative work
perhaps there is some kind of a similar
thing that all other created beings
participate in as an acknowledgement
that god is their creator after all god
created the angels too
not necessarily in a six day format as
he did adam and eve in the earth
but being part of the four uh the fourth
commandment part of god's law
they could very well the bible doesn't
tell us we're kind of speculating but
you'd think that there is some sort of a
continual reminder for all created
beings that god is the creator and a
special time set aside for
focused worship and praise makes sense
that god had a a time some cycle
where the other creatures would come
yeah i don't know if the sabbath is just
for this world he says all flesh but
it's presumed that means all flesh in
the world it will come and worship
before me yeah and of course how big the
universe is there's a lot of beings yeah
isaiah chapter 66 verse 23 this of
course when the earth is recreated at
the end of the thousand years it says it
shall come to pass that from one new
moon to another and from one sabbath to
another all flesh shall come and worship
before me saith the lord now again we
don't know if that's just a reference to
this earth but if you think about it we
know that
god's throne is going to be ultimately
here on this earth when the earth is
recreated so if all of the beings on
earth are coming to worship god would it
make sense that the angelic beings are
from the other worlds the angels would
also participate in that worship on the
sabbath yeah i'm sure that there'll be
some here because we've got guardian
angels yeah we sure do all right well
thanks for your call michael good
question we've got lee listening in
north carolina lee welcome to the
program
oh hi pastor ross pastor doug thank you
so much for taking my call
it is my 60th birthday and i feel like
you guys are a gift directly from the
lord well if you want we'll sing to you
right now but that might just destroy
the whole that's okay
i was baptized just weeks before the
church shut down
um so i've had i've really had a lot of
time with you guys and i so appreciate
you my question um is there really a
talking donkey in the bible and if so
where and what is the um what's that
story
yep there is a talking donkey it's in
the book of numbers i think pastor ross
looks yeah number chapter 22 and you
read it in verse 28 it says the lord
opened the mouth of the donkey and she
said to balaam what have you done
you struck me these three times
yeah and you know it shouldn't shock us
because you've got god speaking through
or not god i'm sorry you've got satan
speaking through a serpent in the very
beginning so the idea of
you know these uh spiritual beings being
able to somehow channel through an
animal
is not a new thing so but i'm sure it
got balaam's attention when the donkey
started talking to him what's really
strange is he talked back to the donkey
that's right
he had a conversation with the donkey
hey i found it funny and i wasn't sure
if it was disrespectful to be laughing
no it is funny
i've got a friend who did a sermon on it
it's called dumb and dumber
you get this dumb prophet
actually the donkey's dumb but the the
prophet is dumber
and yeah it's a great story in the bible
but it is absolutely true and you know
you can see in the bible where
uh you know god used hornets to chase
the enemy god gave elijah food from
crows that brought it every day uh of
course a fish was chosen by the lord to
swallow jonah god incorporates the
animals in many occasions in working
with people
and there's a donkey that brought jesus
that's right that was normally not
supposed to let you ride because it had
never been written
and i've broken horses before and they
usually kick and butt and buck and carry
on and jesus sat on the thing and gave
no resistance
so good question lee if you'd like to
read the whole story just look it up
it's in numbers chapter 22. you'll be
introduced to somebody by the name of
balaam and balak
and also this talking donkey it's a
fascinating story
all right we got jane listening in
oklahoma jane welcome to the program
oh thank you so much i've been enjoying
everybody else
and i almost forgot my question
but thank you for having me
my question is i know the
the word says
so as the tree falleth
so shall it lie
well
after we die
our soul goes back to
god
and
what's the difference between
i've heard so many different people say
that uh the soul and the spirit what's
the difference between that
yeah that's a great question and there
is a difference
and if you look in ecclesiastes 12 and i
forget i think it may be verse seven
when a person dies it says
when any creature dies
says the body returns to the earth as it
was and the spirit returns to god who
gave it it doesn't even differentiate
between man or animal or good or bad
that word spirit there is the word
roach in hebrew and the word roach means
breath it means the breath of life will
return to god who gave it same word
that's used in job where he says is not
the spirit of god in my nostrils well
you're not thinking about some kind of
holy creature in your nose it just meant
the breath of life in my nose so when a
person dies the breath returns to god
who gave it the dust returns to the
earth as it was so when god breathed
into adam he became a living soul god
breathed the breath of life same word
in the new testament it's pneuma where
you get pneumonia it's a breathing
problem
and pneumatic tools for men they run on
air
so a lot of times you see that word
spirits talk about the breath of life
it's not consciousness it's the power of
god for life
the soul
it says when god breathed the breath of
life into adam he became a soul
so you've got the combination of the
body that god made of adam
combined with the breath of life from
god he becomes a living soul you might
say if i've got a handful of nails
and i've got a few planks of wood
i put them together it becomes a box
it doesn't become a box until i connect
those two things if i take out the nails
and set it aside and put the wood back
aside you can say where'd the box go
well it stops being a box when you
separate the two when a person dies
their soul isn't like remobilized i've
got a jump drive here for my computer
you know and i can put all kinds of
stuff on this little thumb drive usb
stick
and it can have my whole computer on
there when i unplug it from the computer
you don't know nothing about nothing
until it's plugged back into the
computer
when in the resurrection
god is going to reunite
our
our breath of life with a new created
body we become a living soul
but the soul is not floating around
disembodied
until the resurrection and some people
teach that and you don't really find it
in the bible
you know just a couple of verses on that
uh jane that you might find interesting
uh ezekiel chapter 8 verse 20 says the
soul that sins it shall die
so that we have the soul dying the bible
doesn't speak of an immortal soul
uh revelation 16 verse 3 says every
living
soul in the sea died let's talk about
animal life talking even about fish and
it's referring to it as a soul
and then the bible tells us that
only god has immortality that's first
timothy chapter 6 15 and 16. so death in
the bible is described as as a sleep as
an unconscious sleep the moment a person
dies their next conscious thought is the
second coming of christ and they are
resurrected they don't realize that time
has passed by to them it's immediate yep
does that help a little bit thank you so
much yeah yes thank you thank you we do
have a free offer pastor ross will tell
you about that we'll help explain this
in more detail yes we have a study guide
that's called are the dead really dead
and it's a very popular study guide we
like to send that out for amazing facts
we'll send that to you jane or anyone
who just called and asked the number is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called are the dead readily dead and
then amazing facts also has a website
called
deathtruth.com that's filled with all of
these passages of scripture
sermon content and and study material so
you might want to check that out just
deathtruth.com
next quarter that we have is matthew
listening in canada toronto canada
matthew welcome to the program
i passed a dog and passed a rust
yeah guys six years ago in kingston
jamaica national stadium ah we remember
that yeah that was a great time yes my
daughter zahara just asked me a question
about revelation 14. okay she wanted to
know if
the
144 thousand was a literal number and
also the other question is if when one
is sealed they can die
all right two good questions and they
are related because talks about the 144
000 having their father's name in their
foreheads which is uh synonymous with
the seal of god
is the 144 000 mentioned in both
revelation 7 and revelation 14 is that a
literal number or is it symbolic
typically the numbers that you find in
revelation have real value
but it doesn't mean the hundred and
forty four thousand are the only ones
saved and that's what makes people
nervous
are there only hundred forty four
thousand saved no they are a special
group keep in mind
jesus chose twelve apostles
to then reach a great multitude when he
came the first time
the 144 000 are something like last day
apostles it's a special group they're
having to reach the whole world now so
god's multiplied the number of these
apostles i'm using that just as a
figurative term
but they're not the only ones saved on
the day of pentecost you've got 120 in
the upper room including the 12 apostles
it's interesting the holy spirit doesn't
fall until they replace judas as soon as
they went from 11 to 12 holy spirit
falls they're sealed with the holy
spirit 120 are in the upper room which
is 10 times more
than just the 12.
and then through their preaching a great
multitude is converted later in chapter
7 it talks about a great multitude that
no man can number that have come out of
great tribulation
and so
i do believe it's a literal number i do
not think in the last days you'll see
people going around with a marathon
number on their back that says i am i am
uh
142 000 or whatever but i think god is
going to spirit fill a group in the last
days that are going to do a great work
of ministry like the apostles did
and we have a book on it we do it's
called who shall sing the song and it
talks about the hundred and forty four
thousand we'll be happy to send this to
you matthew or anyone who calls and asks
the number is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and you know
pastor like there was the second part to
matthew's seal of god he says can you
die after you are sealed and i'm
assuming he's talking about the seal
described in revelation chapter seven
you know once the seven last plagues
begin to fall and probation closes i
don't believe there'll be any martyrs
because they're not really testifying
for anything i think god
delivers them miraculously like he did
when the plagues were i think god spared
all the israelites from plague seven on
right and so i played three on so the
last seven last plagues they were all
spared from and i think god is going to
spare his people from then on
so um people that are sealed with the
holy spirit and what is it revelation 22
he that has just let him be just still
mm-hmm close the probation yeah
probation closes i don't think there's
any martyrs after yeah it seems like
when you look in revelation there's two
groups of people at the end of time
those are the seal of god and those are
the mark of the beast two distinct
groups and it has to do with who they
worship and who do they obey so yes god
will have a group of people in the last
days who are faithful they keep his
commandments
they have the faith of jesus the
testimony of jesus and they proclaimed
the everlasting gospel to the world in
the last days of his history amen all
right well thanks for your call matthew
we've got our next caller paul he's
listening from arkansas paul welcome to
the program
hey pastors how you doing can you hear
me yes loud and clear thank you for
calling wonderful the first time i
called the pastors was three years ago
at the same time i shared i'm a trucker
i went to a church nearby and
man uh they were you know true believers
and uh the teacher when the elder who
does a bible study before the ten
o'clock service
uh we we had a lot of comment anyway so
uh three years passing by and i shared
this with you before uh
somehow conversation came up he believes
you can lose your salvation and this is
what
uh
uh returned to uh ephesians 2 8 10 you
were very gracious you said well you
know what our ministry or i believe the
same thing hope you call back and he
also
believes in the ah millennium and i
believe you believe in the rapture
tribulation so
i tried to explain to him that uh you
know god's not bumping jesus and saying
look at paul look at harold it's
interpretation of scripture but he says
his gift is teaching so since i said
listen you're not going to teach me i i
believe this 20 years just you know like
you know you're not going to you know go
for it once they've always saved so
here's the thing
you believe you can lose your salvation
reference to
ephesians 2 8 10 i believe you can't and
man there's so many scriptures
and of course you're going to work on
good works
uh not to
i and okay so two questions
are you trying to keep your faith or are
you just trying to uh do good works uh
before the lord for your crown because i
believe personally we both
if we're truly saved are going to heaven
thank you
all right hey thanks you know it's
interesting that just
just this sabbath i was teaching on the
subject of once saved always saved both
calvinism and arminianism and what some
of the differences are and that you can
have two extremes in both those areas
and that there are good people
in both camps i know when we get to
heaven i expect to see george whitefield
martin luther john calvin and john
wesley and they all believe different
on this
but um
i'm of the opinion
that
you know you can't go to the altar when
you're nine years old and say i've
accepted jesus and then go lift the
world and say well i'm saved
so
the the fallout of a person believing
that once they're saved that there's no
accountability for their actions
i don't see that in the scripture i do
say that jesus
said it's not everyone that says lord
lord but he that does the will of my
father in heaven and when paul says
we're saved by faith absolutely i don't
believe that
we do the good works to be saved i
believe if we are saved james said
there will be works he said you you know
show me your faith
uh without your works i'll show you my
faith with my works
so the works aren't saving the works are
demonstrating that we have been saved
there's a big difference
an apple tree doesn't produce apples to
prove it's an apple tree an apple tree
produces apples because it is an apple
tree
and so the fruit is a result of what the
tree is
and yeah this has been the the big
debate through history we do have that
book pastor ross can a save man be lost
that uh i think paul would enjoy if he
hasn't read that yet yeah the number to
call for that is 800-835-6747
and as for the book it's called can a
saved man choose to be lost it's got an
intriguing title but filled with
scripture we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks again it's
800-835-6747
thanks for your call uh michael uh next
quarter that we have is um
nayef listening from calgary canada
naoth welcome to the program
thank you so much thank you for
taking my call so this is my second time
i think i called three years ago
uh my question is from matthew 9 37
jesus told the disciple that the harvest
is plentiful but the workers are few
so i just want to know who are these
workers and why are they few
well you know jesus called the apostles
to be what they call under shepherds for
him
to help uh you know
reach in the harvest and pastor
ross might look it up but paul talks
uh it might be in first or second
corinthians about you know i so apollos
waters but god gives the increase and
we're all workers in his field
um
and so
the field is the world jesus gave the
illustration
of a sower goes forth to sow
the seed is the word of god he later
breaks down that illustration
and um
you know you've got people who are
working in the field those are the
um the believers disciples and apostles
and christians
you know we're out cultivating weeding
helping
in spreading the seed of jesus
and then ultimately there's going to be
a harvest and he says the angels come to
help in the harvest they gather together
his elect
the wicked are put in bundles and burned
the righteous brought into the barn
synonym there for heaven
so you know jesus is using all these
metaphors to talk about the gospel in
the world right now there are so many
people who are waiting to hear the
gospel there are not enough laborers to
tell them which is why amazing facts is
doing what we can do we're using
television radio publishing internet
we're trying to do we're doing
evangelism training we try to do
everything we can
to create more laborers in the field
yeah absolutely and you know when we
talk about
the harvest plentiful just look at the
world and see what's happening people
are looking for hope yeah and if there's
a need for people to be willing to share
their faith we're all laborers
tv and the internet there's countries
and people that have not heard about
jesus
it's always amazing to me i'll go to
some foreign country like china talk to
my cab driver there through the
translator and mention i'm a christian
he doesn't know what a christian is
it's it's hard to believe it yeah so the
harvest is still great thank you now
does that help answer your question
yeah i just want to cloud i just want to
clarify something is so if the harvest
is if the harvesters are the angels then
the angels are few because the workers
are few in the field
yeah no i don't think the angels are few
uh you know jesus tells us that there
are a lot of angels he said even at his
crucifixion if i want to i could talk to
my father and he'll call out 12 legions
of angels just for him
i believe that god would
if there's a guardian angel and if the
universe as big as it is it's probably
billions and billions of angels you know
in this context uh matthew chapter nine
jesus is talking about the laborers
being his disciples right uh human
beings that are assisting i'm sure
angels assist in the work of of sharing
the gospel but
really it's it's the people who have
received the gospel and who make it
known to others that's the instrument
that god has chosen to have the gospel
preached in the world amen all right
thank you call we've got uh let's see uh
pebble listening from alabama pebble
welcome to the program
hello dad uh pastor doug and pastor ross
how you doing always better than we
deserve
oh i know it i'm getting over the covet
and so i'm just thanking god that he has
kept me in my family and getting us
strong each day that we pass
well good
amen
um but i have a question i was reading
through
revelation chapter 18
and uh got to
verse 23
and in that verse where it talks about
sorceries were all nations deceived when
i was
studying through that um i looked that
up the word sorceries in greek
and it's it uh meaning is different
it's like a squadron sense it's a
pharmakeia yeah pharmaceutical there you
go is it
kind of significant about like
everything that's going on with the
virus
and stuff do you think that it's like a
prophetic
yeah no i i don't know that it's
connected with the virus and vaccines or
any of that
um
it might be more connected with the drug
addictions in the world today
because in ancient sorcery they often
used
um there were potions there were drugs
you know they offered jesus drugs on the
cross when they offered him gall
and the wine
it was supposed to be you know to help
deaden the pain and he didn't refuse it
he didn't want anything to cloud his
mind but so sorcery you know the devil
through its sorcery has kind of
mesmerized and and bewildered the world
and i think part of that is
he's dead in the world uh through
drugs
of course having pestilence or diseases
pandemics
jesus did say that this would happen
right before the end you can read in
matthew or luke 21 verse 11. you can
also read in matthew 24 but luke 21 11
says and there shall be a great
earthquake or great earthquakes in
various places famines
pestilences
and there'll be fearful signs in heaven
so there it says that with reference to
end time events there will be these
pestilences or diseases and boy have we
found ourselves
in the midst of that verse being
fulfilled and when we see what's
happening in the world today yeah
absolutely
so yeah i was kind of delving more into
that word for sorcery there
and i'd seen that before and yeah it's
it's interesting that it is related to
the word for um
dealing with yeah something that you
would uh take as a drug and the ancient
sorcerers mediums sorcerers witches they
sometimes use potions and brews
uh spells so forth uh but um
there's a lot of witchcraft and
spiritualism in the world today as well
absolutely yep all right well thanks for
your call we might have time for one
more we've got amy listening in northern
california amy we have just about a
minute
okay i'll be quick
had a question when
satan and his angels were
cast out of heaven after the war
and they were banished to earth is that
before adam and eve
yes
yeah good question
um we believe that uh satan and his
angels were banished to earth after adam
and eve were created and they
listened to the temptation of the devil
they surrendered the dominion at that
point
paul says in romans chapter 6 whoever
you obey that's whose servants you are
and when god said don't eat it and the
devil said do eat it when adam and eve
said we're going to listen to the devil
instead of god
satan sort of kidnapped the planet even
jesus said the prince of this world
comes and he has nothing in me that's
why satan told jesus if you bow down and
worship me
i'll give you the world
and
so yeah that's true now listening
friends we are going to be taking a
break here we are going off the air on
one major channel on satellite but we're
coming back with some fast fire rapid
fire amazing facts questions that have
come in on the internet so don't go away
we're back with more
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends we want to welcome those
who are staying with us we have our
special q a session we've got about two
minutes past today we're going to try
and answer as many questions that we can
we've got folks have actually emailed
their bible questions and if you have a
bible question you want to email to us
it's just bal questions at
amazingfacts.org all right here we go
number one pastor doug is the book of
revelation in chronological order
no
i'll give you more of an answer than
that you probably can too but uh no
revelation is basically it's covering
from the first coming of jesus to the
second coming uh and and beyond of
course into heaven but it basically
looks at that time period through many
different divisions you've got the seven
churches you get the seven seals you get
the seven trumpets you get uh the seven
plagues there they're principally at the
end though and so it's each one of them
is taking a facet of history and there's
overlap
so revelation is definitely not written
in chronological order okay next
question that we have uh pastor can you
tell me in from the bible when does the
day begin is it at sunset or is it
sunrise
yeah the bible tells us in leviticus
chapter 23 the lord said from even unto
even
you will celebrate your sabbaths and
they're in genesis 1 it says the evening
and the morning were the first day
so the jews do not start a day at
midnight like the roman time developed
they didn't have clocks there to really
separate it they started a day and ended
a day at sundown
okay very good next question that we
have why does the bible say that we need
to work out our salvation with fear and
trembling if we are saved by faith and
it's a gift
yeah well the lord gives us the gift of
forgiveness and everlasting life but
then he also gives us brains and and
muscle and free choice and that we need
to study we need to pray there's things
you need to do paul said there's effort
he said i strive i run i pray i wrestle
i war these are all terms that denote
there's human
effort that's involved
in the maintaining that relationship but
it's a gift that's given i remember when
somebody came to jesus one time and
asked for a miracle jesus said if you
can believe all things are possible
that's right so there is something we
need to do we need to exercise faith
okay time for another question uh should
christians bury or cremate their dead
well there's no command that's explicit
one way or the other but typically the
example that you see in the bible jesus
said let the bad dead bury the dead
christ was buried abraham isaac jacob
joseph
they were all buried believing that
even in death man retained the image of
god and would be resurrected and it was
a sign of faith
so
not a command but that's the example hey
friends you hear the music that's all we
can cover for today email us more
questions we'll study next week
[Music]